nous merci samir al ghadir la rubrique
les vérificateurs et nous accueillons
maintenant françois bayrou qui pourra
réagir lui aussi à l'actualité à cet
événement dans les alpes maritimes la
visite du présent la république mais
aussi l'autre actualité dominante c'est
la crise du coc vide
la crise sanitaire et la crise
économique françois bayrou ou
commissaire au plan et d'un homme clé du
redressement qui se projette à terme
dans la france sortira de l'ornière
françois bayrou bonsoir et merci d'être
là
beaucoup de questions qui se posent
question des françaises et des français
sur la situation économique
d'abord ces images évidemment qui marque
la journée on les a vus on a entendu
près on a un public est vraiment au
contact des françaises et des français
ces dizaines même ces centaines de
personnes qui sont là qui lui parlent de
leur expérience
donc il y avait le regard non seulement
évidemment que l'on sait dans la
politique maintenant mais historique
la vie politique est ce que c'est un
moment important c'est un moment très
important parce que c'est un moment
d'engagement personnel probablement plus
loin et plus longtemps qu' aucun de ses
prédécesseurs ne l'avait fait on avait
l'habitude des visites présidentielles
compris dans les drames mais ça reste
est resté quelques minutes et puis hélas
le le fait qu' il s'engage
personnellement les yeux dans les yeux
dans des dialogues qui sont des
dialogues vrai est long et que qu'il
accepte d'être pris à partie et que il
attend d'eux il
il ne s'en va pas il reste il était là
jusque jusqu'à il ya quelques minutes
encore il est resté combien six heures
sur le terrain avec ceux qui ont tant
souffert de ce
de ce drame de cet accident
métérologiques vous avez 40 ans de vie
politique plus que ça c'est très bien et
beaucoup de politiciens ils font un peu
semblant il regarde la personne il pense
déjà celle d'après est ce qu'il est
vraiment différent est ce qu'on peut
être différent on peut être différent et
il est différent
1 n'est ce pas il ya eu à mes yeux alors
je prétends pas être extra lucide mais
j'ai regardé cet homme cet homme jeunes
exerçant cette fonction si lourde
tout à l'heure vous interrogez sylvain
fort sûr j'allais dire sur les sur les
rides sur le poids que le président de
la république emmanuel macron comme
personne porte sur ses épaules comme com
com et vous lui demandiez si ce qu'ils
sentaient moi je vais vous dire ce que
je sens je pense que ces rides sont un
plus je trouve que c'était un homme très
jeune quand il a été non je lui avais
dit une fois ça me fait beaucoup de
minutes de télévision il était très
jeune
est ce qui sépare il était très jeune et
il était très jeune avec vous l'avez
souligné aussi dans l'interview avec une
espèce de de joie de vivre nécessaire
quand on fait ce quand on accomplit
cette fonction mais ça donnait aussi le
sentiment que il pouvait croire que les
choses étaient faciles aujourd'hui
personne en france ne peut imaginer que
le président de république croit que les
choses sont faciles l'accumulation de
tsunami d'obstacles de qui là qu'il a
reçue qu'il a pris en pleine figure les
emmerdements dont parlait jean castex en
bon français pas cela en des
emmerdements la gravité cette espèce de
gravité au pouvoir c'est ça vous savez
que c'est un des mots que je préfère
donc
le il a il a échappé à ce qu'est
politiciens dans la fonction pour entrer
dans ce qui est à la fois humain et
historique parce que ça n'est pas une
fonction politique c'est une fonction
qui touche aux raisons du vivre de
chacun d'entre nous françois bayrou
françois bayrou vous fait l'éloge de
l'expérience c'est aussi des loges des
personnages d'expérience on a
l'impression que on retrouve au delà des
manuels macro l'importance de
l'expérience embolique c'est jean castex
c'est vous aussi deux personnages dans
la ma chronique et qui sont encore plus
ou qui reviennent en tête d'affiche est
ce que c'est un signe que ça arrive
maintenant
selon d'abord c'était inéluctable
on a cru pendant un instant où certains
ont cru ou ont voulu croire qu'ils
avaient un nouveau monde faut jamais
avoir ouvert un livre d'histoire pour
craintes y un nouveau monde et votre
sourire le montre assez depuis la
république romaine depuis la rome
antique jusqu'à aujourd'hui les êtres
humains sont les mêmes les réflexes sont
les mêmes le cadre médiatique changent
mais les réflexes d'humains sont les
drames sont les mêmes et la charge qu'un
qu'un chef d'état porte sur les épaules
et la même
et voyez lardons tellement autour d'
emmanuel macron des gens jeunes des
trentenaires un peu geek beaucoup
n'étaient même pas nés quand vous aviez
commencé la crise politique dans l'
équilibre est ce qu'elle me
rééquilibrage selon vous je suis très en
décalage avec ses questions de
génération pour une raison pour moi
évidente c'est qu'un pays c'est toutes
ces générations en même temps
le hasard la chance la providence vous
appelez ça comme vous voulez a voulu que
en france en 2010 est il ya tout d'un
coup un président plus jeune que presque
aucun plus jeune qu aucun de ses
prédécesseurs dans l'histoire ça des
avantages la jeunesse le enthousiasme
mais la vérité est que ça mérite d'être
enrichie par de l'expérience et le fait
que plusieurs générations désormais se
retrouvent à leur place chacun dans
l'équipe qui a la responsabilité du pays
c'est un plus l'expérience est un plus
vous m'avez peut-être déjà entendu dire
ça si je dois traverser l'atlantique
moi qui n'ai jamais traversé
l'atlantique à la voile ni de près ni de
loin
est-ce que je prends un skipper
confirmés qui a déjà fait sans poils ou
bien ce que je prends quelqu'un qui qui
est très beau sur la photo mais qui n'a
jamais fait ça l'expérience est
nécessaire françois bayrou on vous
entendra sur l'expérience sur votre
situation politique sur l'aspect humain
aussi vos relations avec emmanuel a cru
en l'avenir la campagne 2022
d'abord restons à l'instant à
l'actualité plus immédiate c'est la
situation du coc vide situation
économique est là on se rapproche de
votre mission au commissariat au plan
faisant un point du moment la
photographie économique du moment avec
ce qu'elle a de très sombre 1 millions
de nouveaux pauvres
c'est ce chiffre qui était donné par le
journal le monde hier en citant beaucoup
d'organisation des aides aux plus
démunis
la dette qui atteint 114 % du pib et il
ira sans doute plus loin le chômage
partiel prises en charge à 100% qui est
prolongée au moins jusqu'au 31 décembre
est ce que on sous estime ce fardeau
colossal financier économique qui est là
qui tombe sur la france
non le sous-estiment pas vous savez j'ai
passé beaucoup d'années de ma vie à me
battre sur la question de la dette et
c'était quand on m'interrogeait sur
cette question c'était pour dire écoutez
essayons d'être sérieux dans la gestion
aujourd'hui parce que demain peut-être
nous en aurons besoin pour faire face à
des drames profond ce que les allemands
ont fait mieux que le peuple français ne
l'a fait on a été trop imprévoyant en
france mais on a été pendant des années
dans la légèreté de ce qu'ils consomment
en croyant que cet éternel hélas et en
pédiatrie ses 114 % le prix de sa aussi
oui bien sûr puisque les 114 % c'est 14%
qui viennent après les 100 premiers 1
c'est ça qui fait 114 mais cette fois ci
on a raison de faire appel au crédit
j'ai proposé
que cette dette elles soient cantonnées
qu'on isole la dette qu'ovide ce qui est
dû à 7,1 ce tsunami que personne n'avait
jamais imaginé et dont personne n'a la
responsabilité et dans le la dette dans
le gardon va encore s'aggraver c'est la
déclaration du président tout à l'heure
dans ce dernier suivante il dit qu'il
faudra des restrictions supplémentaires
là où le virus circule mais évidemment
vous l'approuvez mais le poids
économique de ça comment est-ce qu'on
peut le prévoir
eh bien on va l'affronter comment est-ce
qu'on peut l'affronter en isolant la
dette due à cette pandémie et en ayant
un report d'échéances
on commencera à rembourser cette dette
grâce à la banque centrale européenne
qui lui revient dans une seconde dans
huit ans donc on aura le temps de
remonter le pays avant de commencer à
faire face aux échéances de la dette
qu'on vient de dépenser françois bayrou
pardon quand on entend tant d'autres
pays en europe qui ne fonctionne pas
comme ça les allemands qui sont très
loin de ses 114 % ils sont à 75 beaucoup
d'autres pays beaucoup plus économes
vous savez bien que je ne vous crois pas
quand vous dites ça ils disent y'a pas
de miracle à la fin les français
s'appauvriront parce qu'il faudra payer
cette charge c'est pas moi qui vais dire
le contraire la dette
un jour ou l'autre il faut l'assumer ça
veut dire que les français vont
s'appauvrir et yvonne offre que cette
réelle je ne crois pas cela je pense que
la stratégie qui a été choisi par
nécessité
grâce à la banque centrale européenne je
vous en dirais deux phrases dans une
minute
cette stratégie qui a été choisi elle
permet de redresser le pays
avant de commencer à faire face à ses
échéances autrement on aurait été dans
une situation dramatique
je m'arrête une seconde à cela où en
serions nous s'il n'y avait pas eu la
banque centrale européenne où serions
nous ça c'est le robert il n'y avait pas
non
oui c'est l'observateur s'il n'y avait
pas l'euro
si on n'avait pas autrefois adopté le
référendum de massiges de si peu
où en serions nous je vais vous dire on
en serait le franc puisqu'on aurait
toujours le franc la banque de france
serait attaquée par tous les
spéculateurs de la planète et on se
trouverait avec des taux d'intérêt
insupportable il serait impossible de
faire face aux obligations d'une relance
mais pardon cette réalité existera aussi
parce que les investisseurs ont en moins
envie d'investir dans un pays surendetté
que dans l'allemagne 75 cette réalité
existera en dehors de la monnaie
ça je ne crois pas le vous ouvrez un
deuxième chapitre qui est est ce qu'on
peut faire de la france un pays
entreprenant créatif attirant pour sa
main d'oeuvre et pour la place des
entreprises de deux qui vont faire face
aux nouvelles demandes alors c'est là
qu'ils ont justement c'est le plan c'est
votre bébé
le haut commissariat au plan très noble
idée de gaulle qu'est ce que c'était sa
formule là le lard et dante obligations
l'ardente obligation mais c'était les
années 60 70 en 2020 dans le monde de
2005 très bien que bon on vous a moqué
on a duré françois bayrou c'est un peu
comme le mini pelle on ressort les
vieilles idées du plan et c'est dans le
monde si concurrentiel si mondialisée si
libéralisé 2020 ça ne marche plus qu'est
ce que vous répondez à ceux là je
réponds que on a eu sous les yeux la
preuve de l'échec de cette stratégie des
intérêts individuels des intérêts
personnels de telle ou telle entreprise
on a voulu laisser faire on a pensé que
les décisions de chaque entreprise
prises pour son intérêt personnel au
bout du compte ça ferait l'intérêt
général il se trouve que là on s'est
aperçu que pendant cette pandémie
on s'est trouvé la france grand pays
médicales et pharmaceutiques
la france s'est trouvée en rupture des
molécules élémentaires pour faire face à
la maladie
on s'est trouvés en rupture des
molécules pour les chimiothérapie pour
les cancers ou quand je dis on s'est
retrouvé en rupture ou presque en
rupture enfin tout le monde a eu peur
corticoïdes antibiotiques le doliprane
men vous savez bien qu'il ya eu de tout
une crainte sur sur ce sujet de
médicaments élémentaire la france et
l'europe parce qu'elle avait délocalisé
pour l'intérêt des entreprises en
question que je remets pas en cause
parce que l'état n'avait pas compris à
temps qu'il y à des domaines dans
lesquels on ne peut pas se désarmer se
déshabiller de ce2 sont deux du plus
élémentaire et du plus urgents on a été
au bord d'un accident supplémentaire de
santé et pourtant et pourtant beaucoup
de ces molécules sont toujours fabriqués
en chine et ailleurs est pas la réalité
économique les masques on a dit on va
faire des masses française on voit bien
made in china qui continue les pneus les
pneus bridgestone est ce que c'est pas
la réalité de la main d'oeuvre c'est
moins cher en pologne qu'en france on se
donne le résultat de il ya évidemment
une part de vrai il ya des différences
de coût de pologne
mais pour moi la pologne c'est l'europe
je ne jouais mais pour les salariés
john oui je ne diffère je ne différencie
pas cet impératif cette exigence cette
obligation qui devrait être celle des
gouvernements de s'occuper de notre
indépendance de la capacité que nous
avons à avoir sous la main
les produits élémentaires de notre
sécurité sans qu'on puisse nous les
enlever en ce bail on part donc et ça
c'est vraiment qu'il y aura quoi qu'il
en soit cette vision étatiste beaucoup
font la comparaison tout simple très
pratique avec les chantiers allemands
c'est très concret les chantiers
allemands pendant le coc vide pendant le
confinement ils ont continué en partie à
fonctionner les français décision
étatiste un peu de la commune on a
arrêté pas vrai on voit bien que il ya
le constat qui est là il faudra
rattraper ça c'est pas vrai le
les entreprises de france l on continue
heureusement bien sûr mais pas tout et
pas au même rythme que certains dans le
mail et on voit le résultat
oui je demande vérifier ce que vous
appelez les chantiers moi je connais les
alors il ya eu en effet un mois trois
semaines d'arrêt complet puisque il
fallait interrompre le virus mais moi je
ne fais je ne peux pas reprocher au
gouvernement d'avoir fait face à
l'urgence sanitaire sais pas vous moi
j'ai perdu des amis très proches qui
étaient en pleine forme et ils sont
morts parce que on a laissé circuler le
virus il ya eu de ce point de vue là un
moment où on aurait dû prendre les
décisions elles n'avaient pas été pris
est ce que ça vous a changé pardon il ya
certains politiciens qui sont passés là
certains parfois expérience personnelle
très forte
est ce que ça a changé votre vision y
compris de l'état du rôle de l'état en
tous cas ça l'a renforcé ces morts là
alors le oui bien sûr mais je voudrais
partager ceci avec vous ce n'est pas une
crise comme les autres les crises on en
a connu un certain nombre 1929 les
lendemains de la guerre de 2008
ce qu'on appelle crise c'est un accident
et après on recommence comme c'était
avant ce que je crois que nous sommes en
train de vivre est d'une nature
complètement différente parce que c'est
notre mode de vie qui change
on ne s'embrasse plus on ne se sert plus
la main on ne se prend plus dans les
bras entre amis on ne va plus dans les
bars ou très peu et ça continuera on ne
voyage plus et il me semble qu'en tout
cas on doit examiner les conséquences de
cette pandémie sur notre vie y compris
économique pourquoi depuis 150 ans le
monde se développe avait selon un
principe qui est le principe des
échanges toujours plus nombreux toujours
plus lointain exponentielle comme on dit
est ce qu'il ya une autre formule je
crois qu'on va devoir expérimente
et d'autres formules et qui sont des
formules de analyse précise de ce dont
nous avons besoin pour vivre et dont
nous ne pouvons pas être privé on a
parlé des médicaments il ya peut-être
d'autres questions qui se posent je
pense aux composants électroniques
si un pays comme le nôtre une une
communauté comme la communauté que
forment l'union européenne se trouvent
privés d'un certain nombre d'éléments
vitaux pour son industrie
à ce moment là ça doit entraîner chez
elle un réflexe de reprise en main de
son propre destin
françois bayrou ses équilibres
économiques l'avenir dira ce qu ils sont
parlant de l' équilibre politique de
votre équilibre aussi aujourd'hui dans
la majorité peut être encore plus
importantes dans le passé parce que là
la république en marche notamment à
l'assemblée a perdu ensemble de plumes
donc comptés d'autant plus avec emmanuel
macron est ce que vous vous êtes trouvé
oui je crois depuis longtemps encore
plus maintenant la cwa dans oui ça s'est
renforcée oui mais je je parle jamais de
mes conversations avec le président
république jeudi aux journalistes qui
m'interrogent extrait excusez moi je
faut que je vous dise j'ai une maladie
que j'hésite à avouer je suis pris d'une
amnésie systématique quand j'ai fini les
conversations mais vous avez le droit
pardon les qualifiés amis amis en
politique on sait que c'est toujours un
peu compliqué est ce que vous êtes ami
jeu je pourrai répondre oui sans
difficulté mais il ya quelque chose
d'autre qui est de l'ordre de la
fraternité de ceux qui combattent
ensemble c'est très vrai quelquefois on
me dit
ça me fait rire on dit mais en fait vous
avez un regard paternel sur lui mais
quoi 22 27 ans de la différence que je
joue comme ça non pas tant quand même je
crois avoir calculé non je crois que
vous êtes trompés bon allez ghana ou de
deux rafale mais disons oui un quart de
siècle de différence c'est paternel donc
non pourquoi parce que j'ai des fils
formidable un unique enfin ils sont pas
uniques mais ils sont formidables
autrefois quand j'étais le lamy le bras
droit de giscard on me disait mais est
ce que ça vous n'avez pas un sentiment
filial à son endroit non parce que
j'avais appris un formidable qui est
mort hélas très tôt et donc non mais
j'ai un regard sûrement de fraternité de
combattants oui ça c'est vrai france
travail de deux c'est à dire de très
grande confiance
j'ai confiance en lui et je pense qu'il
a confiance en moi et ce que l'on vient
de voir encore ces deux c'est de la
confiance est de l'ordre de de
l'affrontement
on donne le plus profond de soi
il ya quand même cette vieille doctrine
militaire qui dit la crainte est la
meilleure garantie d'une alliance il a
besoin de vous et bien de lui
évidemment il aura besoin de vous de
nouveau en 2022 ça aide ça serait facile
pour moi de répondre oui mais je ne veux
pas répondre oui parce que ça n'est pas
mon approche des chemins
il ya des gens qui croient que la
politique c'est perpétuellement des
rapports de force on est du chantage
or en france sous la vème république
rapport de force et chantage ça ne
marche pas c'est le contraire de ce
qu'il faut ce qu'il faut c'est une
adhésion qu'on croit les mêmes choses
qu'on partage qu'on soit décidée à
prendre sa part du fardeau et que on
partage la responsabilité des choses les
plus profondes
mais françois bayrou la voie à
l'accusation quand même au nicolas
sarkozy qui a eu ses formules terrible
sur vous sur la trahison de françois
bayrou ça vous fait sourire parce qu'il
les avait toutes en tête il dit emmanuel
macron en fera à son tour avant la fin
de son quinquennat
l'amère expérience
françois bayrou a toujours trahi ce
qu'il a choisi qu'est ce que vous dites
quand sa prophétie bon j'ai déjà cité
ici et je recommencerai pas des phrases
de jacques chirac sur nicolas sarkozy et
qui je vous assure était infiniment plus
injurieuse et sévère et fondées parce
que lui avait trahi que jacques chirac
ait eu beaucoup de trahison dans tous
les sens être oeuvre être web c'est la
vérité c'était comme ça et chirac n'en
faisait pas mystère dans les
conversations personnelles
il se trouve que moi j'ai jamais trahi
personne pourquoi quand vous dites que
vous allez voter pour françois hollande
en 2009 oui j'ai voté pour françois
hollande parce que j'ai choisi de voter
pour françois hollande pas votre camp
principe mais elle vous venez de suisse
s'est facilement des accordéons
non non non non vous venez de suse c'est
à dire d'un des pays le plus
démocratiquement confirmés qui sait une
chose c'est que la politique c'est pas
des camps vivez vous venez d'un pays qui
prouve tous les jours que heureusement
la politique se limite pas deux camps
j'ai placé toute ma vie politique
sous cet axe sur cet axe là c'est à dire
je suis allé un jour il ya très
longtemps dans une manifestation se
fondait l'ump pour dire vous dit tout ce
qu'on dit qu'on pense tous la même chose
si on pense tous la même chose c'est
qu'on ne pense plus rien la logique des
deux camps est une logique stupide et
criminel salué dans ce sillon vous
entends je vous entends le dos mais
quand on voit votre parcours
effectivement chirac giscard balladur
les complications entre les uns et les
autres les trahisons dans tous les
antillais au texte magnifique de zweig
qui dit en parlant de fouché kenwright
beaucoup de gens il dit mais la trahison
c'est l'autre nom de la liberté les gens
très libre et met ait toujours un peu et
c'est votre cas renom j'ai toujours été
libre
et n'est jamais trahi j'ai adhéré au
parti dont je suis le président
aujourd'hui j'avais 20 ans je ne les ai
jamais quitté et je n'ai jamais accepté
qu'on le place dans une situation de
soumission de qui que ce soit la fin
j'ai dit nylon sociale dont la dette
colossale a dit pas seulement en france
ou si tu l'as eu six aussi deux
démocrates-chrétiens en suisse mais les
allemands les italiens où on a beaucoup
navigué ce que ça fait partie du jeu eh
bien non la famille d'adenauer la
famille de robert schuman excusez moi de
vous dire la qualité principale qui est
la sienne c'est l'intégrité
appelez ça comme vous voulez en tout cas
c'est l'intégrité 1
en tout cas la liberté vous êtes vous
avez beaucoup tourné autour de cette
idée là vous allez faire le best-seller
avec sa séverine sous titre 2-1 là la
fable de la fontaine est ce que c'est
vrai que c'est une de vos références le
chien et loup oui bien sûr vous la savez
parker c'est vrai oui mais je veux pas
vous la réciter oui la sépaq
pourquoi pourquoi cette fable là en
particulier n'ont pas cette fable en
particulier je connais beaucoup de faire
de la fontaine d'abord pas ça a été mon
métier ensuite parce que c'est une
passion j'aime beaucoup la langue
française je trouve qu'on la défend pas
assez
j'aime beaucoup la poésie française et
peut-être n'est pas assez défendu et
j'aime beaucoup le l'espèce de sagesse
qui passent dans l'oeuvre de la fontaine
et qui est la plus la plus acérée qu'on
puisse trouver le le regard que cet
homme la porte
quatre siècles après presque ben il est
toujours aussi percutant aussi précis
sur l'âme humaine
vous parliez tout à l'heure de votre
père décédé de manière précoce grand les
très grands lettrés homme de la terre
mais en même temps grand lettré à lui
vous devez ça aussi hommes de louis
c'est la vérité vraie que je vais vous
dire le
on chargeait du maïs et mon père tenait
la pelle et l'enfant le petit garçon
tenait le sac et ont récité des fables
de la fontaine avec le set
ce geste ancestral qui faisait que le
grain partait dans le sac pour
l'emporter en récitant les fables de la
fontaine et c'est la vérité la plus
stricte la plus réelle des choses
vous vous êtes battu françois bayrou
battu pour mener une carrière il serait
trop long on a rappelé dès l'origine le
nôtre loire c'est quand même taille à
2,6 à classer le combat contre le
bégaiement je regardais tout à l'heure
sur internet la liste des bugs célèbre
ne va pas vous rendre modeste évidemment
yann steinberg jouvet il ya démosthène
et certains même church identique à une
forme de bégaiement c'est le travail et
il ya joe biden way qui va peut-être
être président des états unis et qui lui
aussi s'est beaucoup battu sur ce sujet
il ya un travail sur soi qui est
particulier ou bug très souvent des
petits garçons car ça touche surtout des
petits garçons 1
bellerive pour dire mais qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire alors il ya des exercices et
parfois ça aide mais le fond de cette
affaire c'est que il faut que vous vous
réconcilier avec le petit garçon qui est
en vous et qui est et qui se sent mal
jugé ou qu'on ne le reconnaît pas l
photos de sud ouest on la regardait tout
à l'heure où qui publie une photo de
vous quand vous avez je ne sais pas quel
âge est au bout
est ce que c'est quand vous voyez cette
photo je n'ai pas là on va voir si on la
retrouve mais le combat contre le
bégaiement à cet âge là ça se passe et
comment
franchement c'est cette une affection je
vais dire ou en tout cas à un handicap
alors c'est pas ça c'est pas cette
époque extrêmement désagréable
dégueulasse pour te dire c'est à dire
vous avez les mots en vous et ils sont
même très bien agencé 1 et ils disent
que vous avez de plus profond à
transmettre
et puis tout d'un coup ça bloque
ça passe par un ça bloque on l'entend
parfois dans certaines interviews
oui vous avez bien sûr ça passe jamais
on s'en guérir
c'est pour ça que c'est drôle fait pour
ça c'est lourd ça que c'est marrant être
capable d'apprivoiser quelque chose qui
vous paralyse d'être être capable de
vivre avec moi je trouve que c'est
important est que que c'est drôle voilà
ça oui ça c'est ça c'est là ça c'est cet
âge là où beaucoup plus tard ministre de
l'éducation quand on a eu ce parcours-là
du bégaiement mais ensuite très
brillante carré aussi intellectuel
enseignante s'est mise d'éducation ses
pairs l'aboutissement de ce point de vue
là oui c'était bien c'était bien c'était
pas une surprise parce que dans dans
l'équation de cette époque je trouvais
que oui c'était c c'était ma place c'est
aussi d'ailleurs j'ai demandé pardon
aujourd'hui notamment l'arabe à l'école
c'est un débat de cette semaine
est ce que vous êtes favorable c'est une
des grandes langues du monde alors c'est
l'arabe littéraire en plus c'est pas
l'arabe dialectal des différentes
parties de cet univers je suis pour les
langues
je suis pour les langues anciennes parce
que le latin et le grec c'est un trésor
je suis pour les langues étrangères
l'arabe en est une et après tout
si ça peut être un plus est ce que ces
gars sont les séries d'épreuves
techniques
c'est presque fini parce que je veux
ajouter quelque chose je suis pour les
langues régionales
ouais à bas le béarn qui actuellement
oui qui est la plus pure des langues de
cet espace roman qui a couvert tout tout
tout notre pays en tout cas tout le sud
de notre pays mais sur l'arabe en clair
donc oui vous pensez que ça peut ajouter
du lien social encensé oui elle aussi
l'arabe je pense que c'est un plus et je
suis pour que des français apprennent le
chinois
on a on a installé un institut confucius
à pau alors que tant de grandes villes
n'en n'ont pas françois bayrou je suis
pas d'accord avec le régime
mais je sais que 1 milliard 300 millions
de personnes on a besoin de pouvoir
échanger avec eux et les connaître de
l'intérieur françois bayrou quelques
mots il nous reste quelques minutes sur
le temps qui vient d'ici 2022 situation
très particulière on a vu des sondages
encore dimanche passé où le scénario
semble se réécrire de l'affrontement
inéluctable macron le pen est ce qu'il
est inéluctable d'après mon nom n'est
pas inéluctable de changer mais en tout
cas il dit quelque chose du du pays de
la réalité profonde du pays
est ce qu'un candidat de droite pardon
peut encore émerger il ya cet électorat
énorme
beaucoup disent même la france et de
droite majoritairement et puis y'a pas
de champion et ce qui peut apparaître en
temps mais de l'extrême droite le front
national occupe des positions
extrêmement forte
don est évidemment prétendre qu'il y as
entre qu'il y aurait entre xavier
bertrand ou valérie pécresse ou françois
baroin s'est pas je crois qu'il n'a pas
envie d'y aller mais et emmanuel macron
et le centre gauche prétendent que ces
trois familles seraient irréductiblement
opposé c'est ridicule ça vient le
candidat la droite c'est emmanuel
maintenant c'est parce que je viens de
dire
emmanuel macron et sur le socle du
centre français
le socle du centre français ils pèsent
25% des voix voilà edouard philippe
c'est une possibilité mais oui je ne
crois pas du tout pour 2022
il y a un président de la république qui
conduit une politique dont je puis
affirmer qu'elle n'est différente en
rien sur le fond de ce que conduirait à
un socialiste raisonnable ou un homme de
la droite républicaine à vous embrasser
la main le dire on peut aimer comment et
c'est ça le pays non il y a une
disons extrême gauche les insoumis jean
luc mélenchon une partie des écologistes
ça c'est un courant qui est très
identifié très à gauche il y à une
extrême droite ans à bayrou mairesse
entre ceux qui sont sur le champ
centrale si on vous suit vous avez
pratiqué tant d'hommes
on se rappelle un mitterrand qui
finalement s'est révélé très homme de
droite tout en ayant ce parcours à
gauche en chirac à ses hommes de gauche
tout en ayant ce parcours à droite
emmanuel macron qu'est ce qu'il est au
fond d'après vous pour moi il est le
représentant de cette grande famille du
centre un à la fois soucieux d'identité
française est très européen ça qu'il est
en même temps il sera toujours le cas en
c'est comme ça que kiel qui l'est c'est
pas seulement ce qu'il montre c'est ce
qu'il est et il a cette tâche
d'affronter les plus grands orages et
d'essayer de le faire en donnant au pays
la modernité qui seule peut le souverain
et ben c'est il est courageux pour faire
ça françois bayrou
merci parlez-nous berne est quand même
vous me renvoyez ma condition de suisse
tout à l'heure en faire du régionalisme
vous avez vous fait l'éloge du berne et
commencer le béarnais jamais entendu de
bernay lula ou
si pudi ben ari chaozhou sipo dit
d'abord dot m ce qu est un gorille la
guyane et gratereau baleine tard et
tarde à l'euro du yen
audace in camera parti adulé que je
traduis oui si je pouvais que j'en
ferais des choses si je pouvais d'abord
du temps j'arrêterai l'éguille à mon gré
et trop ardente pour retarder leur
douloureuse ou dc il faudra que je m'en
aille faudra toujours cent vallées à la
fin où m être président de la république
c'est fini ce rêve là étaient enterrés
personne ne connaît l'avenir vous avez
des candidats trois fois oui
quatrième ce possible maman fire on a
failli gagner me demander aux ans qui se
présente à chaque fois n'a failli gagner
en 2007
merci beaucoup françois bayrou d'avoir
été notre invité merci beaucoup et la
suite tout de suite c'est le grand soir
avec julien en no mercy paix à demain
[Musique]